frau präsidentin einer sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen wir sind der
haushaltsdebatte für das
bundesgesundheitsministerium ich möchte
beginnen indem ich mich zunächst einmal
bei allen haushälterinnen und haushälter
für die guten beratungen ganz herzlich
bedanken
wir haben einen großen haushalt hier zu
verabschieden der haushalt schrumpfte
allerdings von derzeit 64 milliarden auf
22 milliarden im nächsten jahr also auch
um ungefähr ein drittel dass es damit zu
erklären dass wir davon ausgehen dass
die pandemie im nächsten jahr uns nicht
mehr vor teure und unlösbare probleme
stellen wird ich rechne damit dass wir
in diesem herbst noch einmal
schwierigkeiten bekommen für diese sind
wir aber sehr gut vorbereitet diese
vorbereitung werde ich später vortragen
in der diskussion um das
infektionsschutzgesetz ich konzentriere
mich jetzt auf die situation wie wir das
gesundheitssystem
modernisieren werden aber ich möchte
darauf hinweisen dass ich davon ausgehe
dass wir im herbst die pandemie lage gut
im griff haben werden und das werde ich
später ausfuhren
jetzt geht es um die zukunft unseres
gesundheitssystems unter sind im
hintergrund zahlreiche projekte der
modernisierung weitergeführt wurden ich
werde mich in meiner rede auf mehrere
bereiche konzentrieren ich fand zunächst
einmal an in dem ich darauf eingehen
werde was wir verändern werden in der
pflege dann werde ich auf krankenhaus
reformen zu sprechen kommen dann den
bereich der digitalisierung und dann
schließlich das was wir für sozial
benachteiligte menschen tun wollen um
das gesundheitssystem gerechter zu
machen ich fange einmal an mit der
pflege in der pflege haben wir
tatsächlich wichtige reformen vor uns
und eine ganz konkrete reformen so
genannte krankenpfleger
entlastungsgesetz beschäftigt sich mit
dem problem was machen wir eigentlich
gegen die chronische überlastung der
pflege in vielen stationen auch in
vielen bereichen was wir dort machen ist
zunächst einmal wir gleichen ab durch
ein instrument wo man den pflegebedarf
vergleichen kann mit der pflege die
angeboten wird welche stationen sind
eigentlich besonders überlastet und wenn
wir diese überlastung sagen feststellen
dann kommt an der entsprechende
entlastung entweder durch mehr
urlaubstage durch entlastungs tarife
oder durch zuschläge die steuerfrei und
abgabenfrei organisiert werden können
das führt dazu dass tatsächlich die
pflege als arbeitsplatz wieder
interessant als man kann ja zunächst mal
die frage stellen was bringt es denn
überhaupt wenn ich nur auf der station
die überlastung der pflege dokumentiere
naja wenn wie in diesem gesetz
vorgesehen dann tatsächlich eine
entlastung auch kommt dann wird die
pflege als arbeitsplatz wieder
interessanter und wir wissen dass
ungefähr 300.000 pflegerinnen und
pfleger bereit sind im prinzip wieder in
die pflege zurückzukehren dieses gesetz
wird dazu einen wesentlichen beitrag
leisten das ist der grund weshalb das
gesetz auch von den gewerkschaften nicht
nur unterstützt sondern auch gefordert
wird dafür bedanke ich mich wir werden
mit diesem gesetz gartenpflege wieder
deutlich attraktiver machen und den
pflegenotstand entgegenwirken
im krankenhaus muss mehr geschehen und
ich fange mit einem bereich an der mir
besonders am herzen liegt und zwar den
kinderkrankenhaus und wir haben ungefähr
350 kinder kliniken abteilungen und
kliniken für kinder- und diese kliniken
haben den letzten jahren deutlich
gelitten auch dort gibt es einen
reformstau jahren dort etwas vorbereitet
und zwar eine weitgehende reform und
zwar dass die kinderkliniken komplett
aus dem bereich der vater schalen
entfernt werden damit wird der druck der
ökonomische druck auf diese kliniken der
wird von jetzt auf sofort wird er
beendet die kliniken können dann wieder
die kostenabrechnung bekommen ein budget
und müssen nicht durch
leistungssteigerungen quasi das budget
sich von jahr zu jahr erkämpfen neu
erkämpfen das tier habe dann an bereich
der komplett ohne die pauschalen im
wesentlichen nach dem system der
kostendeckung funktioniert gerade bei
den kindern ist das unbedingt
notwendiges kann nicht länger akzeptiert
wenn was wir viel zu lange akzeptiert
haben dass in der kinder
krankenhausversorgung ökonomische
aspekte im prinzip einfluss auf die
therapien schaden haben das können wir
nicht hinnehmen
von daher ist das eingesetzt was wir mit
den vorbereitenden wir noch mehr geld in
die hand nehmen kinderheilkunde würden
klicken deutlich lassen wir je nach 2000
krankenhaus wir werden auch die fahrt
auch schalen allgemein entlasten und
zwar dank die forscher haben das hat
keiner vorhaltekosten die pauschal sind
die abdecken wie stark ist ein
krankenhaus eigentlich gebraucht die
fallpauschale gibt im prinzip den
gleichen preis in einer region wo sehr
viele krankenhaus ergebnis schon
überversorgung gibt und regionen wo es
eine unterversorgung gibt wir wollen
hier ist durch eine vorhatte pauschale
dort mehr geld hin steuern wo die
krankenhäuser unbedingt benötigt werden
und dafür soll es abschläge geben
relative abschläge geben dort wo an
überversorgung ist damit steuern wir im
prinzip liegt krankenhausversorgung sehr
viel besser wir geben anreiz so dass
tatsächlich die demographische und die
medizinische situation dafür
verantwortlich ist wo investiert wird
auch das ist eine wichtige eine sehr
sehr wichtige and economy sierung
unserer krankenhausversorgung überfällig
sie kommt jetzt die wird vorbereitet wir
sind mit den sachverständigen schon in
einer konkreten umsetzungsplan
nichts vergessen werden darf dass wir
auch die kurzfristigen bedürfnisse der
krankenhäuser hier berücksichtigen wir
werden die energiekosten inflations
kosten die rück zurückgegangenen fahr
zahlen werden wir also analysieren wir
werden ein hilfspaket schnüren damit die
karten aus er jetzt nicht in der
situation wo 40 prozent der krankenhaus
liquiditätsprobleme haben in
unüberbrückbaren schwierigkeiten kommen
noch da arbeiten wir haben nach einer
kurzfristigen lösung wir lassen in
dieser energie und inflations krise
lassen wir unsere krankenhäuser nicht im
stich und während sie über den herzen
über den winter bringen das haben wir
vor dafür werden wir konkrete vorschläge
in den nächsten wochen vorlegen und mit
den ländern des
schließlich komme zum bereich der
digitalisierung in betrieb
digitalisierung des gesundheitswesens
ist der bereich über den am meisten
gesprochen wird und wo am wenigsten
kassieren wir sind nach wie vor was
digitalisierung an gibt im prinzip im
europäischen vergleich ein
entwicklungsland wir können nicht
mithalten mit ländern wie dänemark den
niederlanden geschweige denn mit ländern
ausserhalb von europa zum beispiel
israel wo einfach viel mehr möglich ist
viel mehr möglich ist was wir jetzt
machen wir bauen auf die pandemie hat ja
nur nachteile gebracht die schreckliche
pandemie hat nur nachteile gebracht aber
in einem bereich hat sie tatsächlich
etwas angeschlossen in der
digitalisierung bei der digitalisierung
ist es zu viel mehr fehler spricht und
gekommen tele konsultationen in das
elektronische rezept es möglich geworden
wir haben pflegeberatung digitalisiert
wir haben mit der krone waren heftig
versicherten quasi herangeführt die
digitalisierung wir wollen darauf
aufbauen wir sind da hier sozusagen in
eine kurve eingebogen wir wollen aus der
kurve herausbeschleunigen und wir wollen
einführen das elektronische rezept
letzte woche eingeführt wir wollen ein
für die elektronische
arbeitsunfähigkeitsbescheinigung 23
millionen mal schulen genutzt bis zum
august wir wollen die elektronische
patientenakte als ob auch lösungen
einführen damit ist sozusagen jeder
zunächst einmal mit einer elektronischen
patientenakte unterwegs und wir wollen
diese dann aber auch für
forschungszwecke nutzen indem wir das
system was in israel praktiziert wird
des digitalen zwillings nutzen um aus
routinedaten heraus forschung machen zu
können so dass wir aus den routine von
daten heraus sehen können welche
behandlungskonzepte sind effizienter
funktionieren besser das ist ein
wesentlicher schritt nach vorne dafür
reißen wir wir sind mit den israelis
diesbezüglich im engen kontakt aber
dafür reißen wir am samstag mit einer
delegation von experten nach israel und
werden einen kooperationsvertrag
unterschreiben wir orientieren uns hier
an den besten und israel ist was die
digitalisierung des gesundheitssystems
angeht weltweit führend das wollen wir
auf trafen überein mit den besten
zusammenarbeiten und greifen das auch
aus der kurve herausbeschleunigen
digitalisierung wird ein wesentlicher
schwerpunkt der arbeit unseres hauses
werden
und lassen sie mich
und lassen sie nichts zum schluss noch
einmal sagen wir müssen heute hast du
und für die ärmsten wir dürfen sie nicht
so klasse wir wollen mit 1000
gesundheits kiosken das sind 1 das sind
neue strukturen wo man an den termin
bekommt für ein fach ersten superstar
hausbesuche vorbelastung und abgerufen
werden können wo soziale dienste abrufen
werden können wo hebammen dienste also
vermittelt werden kann wo man
übersetzungen bekommen kann pro pflege
beratung stattfinden kann wobei
ernährungs brand mit 1000 kioske in den
ärmsten oder in einigen der ärmsten
stadtteile und regionen deutschlands
bauen wir eine neue struktur auf ist
längst hätte geben müssen dass es in den
ärmeren stadtteilen eine
niederschwellige schnelle route
zugangsmöglichkeit geht für die menschen
auch die menschen die die sprache nicht
gut sprechen auch die menschen die zum
beispiel gar keine versicherung noch
keine versicherung haben diejenigen die
keine richtigen guten zugang haben wir
müssen das machen das spart auch geld
das spart mordfall anpassung das spart
krankenhauseinweisung das führt zu einer
besseren medizin wir helfen dir den
ernsten das ist uns sehr wichtig was wir
aus einer priorität ausbauen wir haben
viel vor wir machen viel auch schon im
hintergrund wird nicht nur pandemie
sondern wir machen fehlen für die
modernisierung des ist klar dass sie
davon weder etwas verstehen noch
mitbekommen aber es ist so das ist so
und ich danke den ich kannte die in
diesen weg und leitet haben euch dahin
auch für den großzügigen haus hat den
werden wir benötigen und den werden wir
effizient tasche
der bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach zu seinem etat für das jahr
2023 corona die pandemie hatte anfangs
erwähnt da wird er nachher eben der
debatte über das infektionsschutzgesetz
ausführlicher zu berichten hat er eben
angekündigt ansonsten die schwerpunkte
pflege mit dem krankenpflege
entlastungsgesetz die krankenhaus reform
wo insbesondere die kinderkliniken im
blick hat und das thema oder großes
thema die digitalisierung im
gesundheitswesen wie das elektronische
rezept oder die elektronische
patientenakte
ich gehe davon aus dass sie damit
einverstanden sind und damit entfallen
diese tagesordnungspunkte und das wort
geht an sepp müller für die cdu csu
bundestags vizepräsidentin hat auf ein
paar punkte wir strichen von der
heutigen liste des bundestages aber da
geht es natürlich nicht um die einzelnen
der bleibt alles so wie es ist nächster
redner sepp müller aus der
unionsfraktion einer der
stellvertretenden vorsitzenden ihrer
worte höre ich gerne allein mir fehlt
der glaube faust johann wolfgang goethe
kommen sie endlich aus dem modus des
ankündigungsminister in den minister
werden sie gesundheitsminister verlassen
sie die korona pandemie und kümmern sie
sich um unser gesundheitssystem
sie hatten nach der letzten welle in
früher angekündigt dass endlich zeit ist
um gesetzesvorlagen vorzulegen aus ihrem
haus kamen zwei die gesundheits kiosk
1000 an der zahl angekündigt wissen sie
was ein gesundheits kiosk im ländlichen
raum und für die meisten stände bedeutet
das ist die hausarztpraxis wir brauchen
satz praxen
4000 hausarztpraxen in unserem land sind
seit über zwei jahren nicht besetzt und
sie diskutieren 1000 zusätzliche
gesundheits kioske wo das material nicht
da ist wo das geld nicht vorhanden ist
wo das personal fehlt massiv vorgelegt
haben ist ein finanz
stabilisierungsgesetz für die
gesetzliche krankenkasse
das ist weder ausreichend noch der lage
und vor allem den problemen in unserem
land
gerecht schauen wir unseren haushalt an
dann kann der geneigte leser zu dem
entschluss kommen dass der
bundesfinanzminister mit dem roten stift
dem roten karl lauterbach etwas diktiert
hat
ihre ideen für diesen haushalt
umfassen keine seltenen erkrankung
wie sieht es aus mit den tausenden ms
erkrankten was ist mit der
volkskrankheit alzheimer wie geht es
weiter mit der bundeszentrale für
gesundheitliche aufklärung all das herr
lauterbach haben sie in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag festgehalten und wir
finden in ihrem haushalt nichts kommen
sie weg vom ankündigungsminister werden
sie endlich gesundheitsminister
und er laut aber nur ein wort zu corona
sie haben ende letzten jahres anfang
dieses jahres sich mit millionen
impfdosen
eingedeckt diese werden jetzt verfallen
das sind dreistellige millionenbeträge
die an steuergeld verbrannt war hätten
sie dieses geld medizinischen
fachangestellten
zahnmedizinischen fachangestellten als
bonus gezahlt dann wäre das der respekt
gewesen den wir auch von einem
gesundheitsminister für diese branche
erwarten
der gesundheitsminister die finanzierung
der gesetzlichen krankenversicherung
steht auf tönernen füßen bereits jetzt
werden knapp 17 milliarden euro
angenommen die fehlen mit der inflation
werden wir bei 25 milliarden euro
herauskommen sie sprachen davon als sie
das gesetz eingebracht haben nicht an
der qualität zu
streichen und zu arbeiten was legen sie
vor sie wollen die neue patienten
regelung für ärzte streichen wissen sie
was das für hausärzte und fachärzte
bedeutet sie werden an der qualität
streichen weil sie neue patienten junge
patienten patienten die von a nach b
umziehen noch keinen termin da geben
können weil das budget voll ist sie sind
der minister die axt an die wurzel des
qualitätssystem in unserem
gesundheitswesen anlegen sie haben da
versagt der lauterbach
und wenn sie alleine das umsetzen würden
was in ihrem koalitionsvertrag steht wie
die beteiligung des
bundesfinanzministeriums und jasmin
ministeriums bmhs bei der frage der
finanzierung der gkv sprich die alg 2
empfänger komplett mit zu beteiligen
hätten wir zehn milliarden zusätzlich
zur verfügung und die brauchen wir und
liebe sozialdemokratie da haben sie uns
an ihrer seite da werden wir sie auch
unterstützen das muss jetzt endlich auf
den weg gebracht werden und ja lauter
werden sie endlich gesundheitsminister
und kommen sie weg von den anderen
zählen danke
wohl aber dass aus der unionsfraktion
zum etat des bundesgesundheitsministers
und ich kann ihnen auch fix nach tragen
welche punkte hier heute nicht
aufgerufen werden das ist nämlich die
wahl eines vize-präsidenten aus den
reihen der fdp und die wahl eines
mitgliedes für das parlamentarische
kontrollgremium auch da fehlt noch ein
vertreter oder eine vertreterin der afg
beide wahlen finden nicht statt weil die
afg von sich aus diesem
tagesordnungspunkt quasi zurückgezogen
hat am pult ist paula piotta für bündnis
90/die grünen
mitglied im haushaltsausschuss und
ärztin übrigens
aber wenn es jetzt hier hinstellen und
sagen brauchen ein minister und das nur
knapp zwölf monate nachdem jens spahn
abgetreten ist wo wir alle wissen dieser
dieser ansatz von politik viel zu machen
mit den konsequenzen dass da einfach
unglaublich viel geld aus dem fenster
rausgeworfen wurde sie haben ich bin
nicht in alle inhaltlichen punkte 1
einsteigen weil ich nicht im
fachausschuss mit mithaftung sitze aber
wenn sie jetzt hier zum beispiel den
patienten regelungen ansprechen sie tun
so als auch die streichung unglaubliche
unterschiede in der versorgung machen
würde sie erwähnen nicht wie wenig neue
patienten diese regelung tatsächlich
geschaffen hat wie viele zusätzliche
arzttermine sie tatsächlich geschaffen
hat oder aber eben nicht was wir jetzt
machen müssen nach soviel zeit union und
vor allen dingen auch jens spahn im
bundesgesundheitsministerium
der regiert hat in zeiten wo er klotzen
konnte und eben oft nicht aufs geld
geschaut hat ist dass wir das jetzt
ausbaden und das unglaublich schwierigen
sind ihre rahmenbedingungen tun weil
einfach das geld uns jetzt an einigen
enden fehlt und hierzu zu tun es auch
karl lauterbach nicht mit geld umgehen
könnte wenn man selber die partei der
masken die es ist der betrugsfälle in
den geschäftszentren ist vielleicht ein
bisschen unvorsichtig und sumatra
und jetzt möchte ich dann doch wieder
über das geld sprechen aber noch mal
daran erinnern wie das war am anfang der
panini am anfang der pandemie wo wir
alle aus unserem alltag raus geworfen
waren und wo tatsächlich gefühlt
gesundheitspolitik in deutschland zum
ersten mal viele menschen interessiert
das war ja wirklich gerade für menschen
die viel gesundheitspolitik gemacht
haben eine sehr besondere situation und
dann fiele auch hier im bundestag die
hoffnung gehabt dass sich nach der
pandemie unglaublich viel im
gesundheitswesen verbessern würde gerade
auch beschäftigte im gesundheitswesen
die sehen jetzt so viel hat sich gar
nicht verändert
und die haben die blöde vermutung dass
wir aus dieser pandemie herauskommen
könnten mit genau den gleichen problemen
aber noch weniger geld im
gesundheitswesen und damit auch noch
schlechteren arbeitsbedingungen sie in
die kliniken und praxen und deswegen
muss man schon mal darauf hinweisen dass
es dann doch lerneffekte aus der
pandemie gibt auch wenn diesem
gesundheitstag der etat des
gesundheitsministeriums der finanziert
nicht das komplette gesundheitswesen der
es mal ein bruchteil dessen was die
kassen in diesem wesen leisten aber auch
an diesem etat sieht man wie die
lerneffekte der korona pandemie jetzt
auch ganz konkret umgesetzt werden wir
haben zum beispiel und der minister hat
sie angesprochen wir hatten dieses und
diesen unglaublichen aufwuchs von vor
der pandemie knapp 15 milliarden etat in
weniger als drei jahren quasi
vervierfacht auf über 60 und jetzt
nehmen wir das wieder zurück auf knapp
22 milliarden im entwurf das zeigt aber
auch wir gehen nicht auf vorkrisenniveau
zurück sondern wir bleiben deutlich mit
den 22 milliarden über dem vor
pandemischen und da sind punkte drin die
lerneffekte darstellen aus der panne wie
zum beispiel nicht möchte auf drei
punkte angehen weil ich auch glaube dass
wir die alle über alle fraktionen hinweg
gut im blick behalten sollten weil die
teilweise auch sehr teuer sind aber
nicht nur weil sie teuer sind wir
steigen jetzt mit diesem entwurf einen
die sogenannten pannen die bereitschafts
verträge das ist neues ins da geben wir
herstellern als bund hohe dreistellige
millionenbeträge über mehrere jahre an
die hand damit sie kapazitäten vorhalten
für impfstoffproduktion fasst es
nochmals einer epidemischen oder
pandemischen lage kommt und das müssen
wir alle sehr genau im blick behalten
vor allen dingen auch ob die kapazitäten
die da geschaffen werden sollen
tatsächlich auch zuverlässig geschaffen
werden die beratungshotlines für die
patienten werden weitergeführt es ist
auch eine errungenschaft der pandemie
und was auch eine errungenschaft ist
bisher die erkenntnis ist gerade in der
frühphase der pandemie die whu nicht
immer so effizient die frühe detektion
die früher vorrang die frühe beratung
von regionen und ländern geleistet hat
und deswegen finanzieren wir jetzt
weiter den bh oberhalb von pandemic
intelligence und werden das hier in
berlin als zentrum etablieren wo eben
für detektion und warnung und beratung
für alle regionen und länder dieser welt
geleistet wird das sind verbesserung in
diesem etat aber natürlich ist es so
dass in diesem tag gerade auch aus sicht
von gesundheitspolitikerin und
gesundheitspolitikern natürlich
unglaublich viel luft nach oben ist und
ich kann für uns sprechen vor allen
dingen die punkte prävention
modernisierung gesundheitswesen und
internationale gesundheitspolitik wenn
wir uns noch mal sehr genau anschauen
aber
jetzt möchte ich noch mal auf die
haushaltspolitischen lehren aus der
krone panini für diesen etat kommen gab
es da schon gesagt ich möchte eine
zwischenfrage zu lassen aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion ausnahmsweise nicht
aber ich kann gleich vorbei ich habe
schon gesagt von knapp 15 milliarden
euro und drei jahren hat sich dieser
etat wirklich das ist kann man nicht als
organisches wachstum bezeichnet
vervierfacht auf über 60 milliarden und
die möglichkeiten und die realisierung
der kontrollmöglichkeiten ist da auch
nicht in gleichem maße mitgewachsen
und deswegen sie auch haushaltspolitisch
aus dieser zeit lernen auch in der krise
auch im gesundheitsbereich auch wenn wir
jetzt in die nächste krise gehen und ihr
begegnen müssen brauchen wir den fairen
lastenausgleich zwischen bund und
ländern teilweise auch den kommunen es
gilt auch im gesundheitsbereich und es
muss auch im dritten und vierten
pandemie jahr gelten und eben nicht nur
im ersten wie wir das erlebt haben auch
in der krise müssen wir sicherstellen
dass steuergelder so ausgegeben werden
das betrug verunmöglicht wird das ist
eine enorm große lehre aus der bonner
zeit gerade im einzelplan 15 wir sehen
jetzt dass teilweise gelder zurück
fließen aus betrugsfällen aber dass es
nur ein bruchteil dessen was
wahrscheinlich wirklich nicht bei
patientinnen und der bevölkerung
angekommen ist und wir müssen natürlich
auch schon vier stellen gerade wenn
jetzt eine krise nach der anderen kommt
und dass eine hilfspaket das nächste
ablöst dass das was wir an
kriseninterventionen machen nicht unsere
mittel und langfristigen ziele im
gesundheitswesen zum beispiel im bereich
krankenhauslandschaft konterkariert
deswegen sehen sie es uns bitte nach wie
haushälter werden auch in diesem
haushaltsberatungen uns wieder sehr
genau jeden einzelnen euro anschauen bei
jeder einzelne euro der hier eben nicht
dafür ausgegeben wird das
gesundheitsversorgung besser und
arbeitsbedingungen im gesundheitswesen
attraktiver werden das ist ein euro der
eine verpasste chance für bessere
lebens- erwartungen und deswegen und
deswegen sind es uns da wir werden das
wieder sehr genau beraten kind
der bundesgesundheitsminister hat so gut
gehen dieser debatte gesagt dass er sich
später mit der pandemie beschäftigen
wolle die abgeordneten beschäftigt das
thema schon jetzt paula potter zum
beispiel eben ist unter anderem
eingegangen auf betrugsfälle im
gesundheitswesen rundum kurbelt 19 und
jetzt einer kurzintervention aus den
reihen der union
auch der grüne teppich wird er immer
behauptung in den raum stellen und wenn
dann der bereich gestellt werden sollte
diese zwischen eigentlich zu lassen eine
kurze lektion
mich würde interessieren ob sie mit mir
auch einer meinung sind wenn sie hier
schon ankündigen und sagen wir brauchen
gerade als ergebnis als erkenntnis aus
der pandemie wieder den besseren
gesundheitsstandort in deutschland
sprich produktion forschung entwicklung
wir brauchen hilfe für den
gesundheitsstandort stichwort
energiepreis explosionen in den kliniken
brennt die hütte lichterloh das wissen
sie wir werden erst insolvenzen bekommen
wir werden wenn die regierung weiter so
untätig bleibt wirklich
versorgungsproblem da bekommen weil
klinik schließen müssen dass sie sich
hier hinstellen und in einer süffisanten
art zu tun wir werden machen wir könnten
der bundesgesundheitsminister hier
wieder nur ankündigung gebracht hat ich
sage immer wir können froh sein dass es
in deutschen die im konjunktiv gibt er
möchte er wird er könnte ob sie mit mir
auch einer meinung sind dass viele
unternehmen die rahmenbedingungen so wie
sie in deutschland sind insbesondere im
hinblick auf neue technologien als
völlig unzureichend erachten
mittlerweile weil sie nichts tun und
sich hierhin zu stellen und so zu tun
als gäbe es keine probleme
das finde ich wirklich alle alle achtung
wert aber das geht an der sache völlig
vorbei
ich hatte möchten sie antworten
dann gebe ich jetzt das wort an den
kollegen wolfgang wehle für die afg
fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen von 64
milliarden auf 22 milliarden die korona
fieberkurve des gesundheits etats geht
deutlich zurück
aber erhöhte temperatur muss man beim
blick auf die zahlen immer noch
feststellen während andere länder zur
normalität zurückkehren kann sie herr
minister lauterbach wieder über zwei
milliarden euro für neue impfstoff
käufer ein während vorhandene
überbestände vom verfallsdatum rot
werden
es ist ein unterschied ob man dem
angesicht neuartiger gesundheitsgefahren
das nötige tut oder ob man den menschen
angst macht um sich anschließend als der
große retter in szene setzen zu können
das habe ich ihnen schon an dass sich
der beratung des haushalts 22 gesagt
jetzt sind wir ein halbes jahr weiter
ihre alarmmeldungen wirken zunimmt
hysterisch und skurril deutschland wird
immer mehr zum gesundheitspolitischen
geisterfahrer
eine konstante hat der gesundheits
haushalt aber und diese stücke
ausgesprochen nachdenklich die
pharmaindustrie profitiert mit
zehnstelligen beträgen nicht nur durch
die impfstoff beschaffung sondern auch
durch ihre sogenannten pandemie
bereitschaftspflege
natürlich kann man sich keine welt sich
zurecht legen in der uns große global
aufgestellte konzerne vor den gefahren
des lebens immer besser bewahren die
technologische machbarkeit trägt uns
durch diese brille betrachtet in ein
leuchtendes neues zeitalter
aber ist diese art von
fortschrittsglauben nicht völlig naiv
ist der drastische anstieg von
arztbesuchen wegen impfnebenwirkungen
zufall ist das auftauchen des neuartigen
plötzlichen erwachsenen zufall ist das
plötzliche absinken der geburtenziffern
in westlichen ländern zufall oder
versagt die technologie in vielen fällen
und versagen die regierungen und die
meisten medien im umgang damit
das was man in zahlen klaren messen kann
sind freilich die zweistelligen
milliardengewinne bestimmter
pharmaunternehmen sowie das corona virus
und erwartet über uns hereingebrochen
ist halte ich diese gewinne für zu
fangen etwas anderes will ich niemandem
unterstellen in der logik der politik
dieser regierung
müssten solche sogenannten zufalls
gewinne eigentlich abgeschöpft werden
notlagen gibt es derzeit viele in denen
mehr geld dringend gebraucht wird die
deutsche krankenhausgesellschaft schlägt
alarm angesichts der inflation die diese
regierung mit ihrer energie und
sanktionspolitik shirt
gleichzeitig droht dass sich pflege im
alter nur noch die leicht die reichen
leisten können diese regierung hat
nämlich völlig verschlafen die
tarifanpassung beim pflegepersonal dafür
vorzusorgen und nun gehen die
eigenbeiträge der betroffenen durch die
decke
wir werden in den nächsten wochen
diskutieren ob erhöhte zuschüsse für
krankenkassen und pflege die angemessene
reaktion sind wir werden fragen wie die
versorgung durch krankenhäuser auch in
der fläche gesichert wird wir fragen
aber auch warum die reguläre
öffentlichkeitsarbeit des ministeriums
nun sieben statt fünf millionen euro
kosten sollen
darauf ist verlass die fdp-fraktion
achtet jenseits der politischen
fieberkurven immer darauf dass das geld
des gesundheitsministeriums für die
dinge ausgegeben wird die die leute in
unserem land wirklich brauchen
[Applaus]
karsten klein spricht jetzt für die fdp
fraktion
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ja formal herr
minister werden die mittel in ihrem
haushalt 2023 sehr stark zurückgefahren
es liegt in erster linie sie haben
dasselbe angesprochen ja daran dass wir
die korona ausgaben heraus wachsen und
die wachsen aus zwei gründen heraus auf
der eigenen seite
beurteilen wir die lage für 2023 so dass
sie nicht nötig sind aber ich sage auch
ganz bewusst dazu wir erwarten natürlich
auch nach so einer langen zeit dass
viele kosten die nta coroner zeit vom
bund übernommen worden sind aber
eigentlich länder aufgaben sind im
zweifel dann auch von den ländern
endlich übernommen werden dass die
entsprechenden strukturen vorhanden sind
dass die länder reagiert haben ihre
gesundheits ende auf vordermann gebracht
haben die digitalisierung dort endlich
ein geführter alles länder aufgaben die
wir als bund kitten mussten um wo ich
davon ausgehen wenn 2023 ist noch mal
ernst wird die länder dann auf eigenen
füßen stehen können
wie ernst die länder rechnen konnte man
dieses jahr bei der debatte im april um
die verlängerung der test verordnung
sehen also ich weiß nicht ob sie sich
noch erinnern wir hatten an der sehr
intensive debatte weil bisher ist es so
dass ja die tests die bürger test die
eigentliche aufgabe der länder sind
komplett vom bund übernommen worden sind
und dann gab es intensive debatte und
viele länder gesundheitsminister vor
allem aus meinem heimatland bayern jagen
die bürger test unheimlich wichtig dass
die kostenlos weitergeführt werden wir
haben dann in einigen schönen weg
gefunden herr minister nämlich dass es
bei einer zahlung von 3 euro geben
weiterhin diese tests gibt und wo wunder
kein einziges bundesland hat danach es
die kostenlosen test noch so wichtig für
gefunden in der pandemie bekämpfung das
ist die drei euro übernommen hätte und
ich glaube das ist beispielhaft wie die
länder in dieser krise hervorgehen alles
was der bund bezahlt wird alles was
kostenlos ist nimmt man mit aber selber
bringt man zu geringe beiträge und das
ist nicht akzeptabel in einer solchen
krisensituation
der einzelplan des bmg wird ja schon
immer sehr stark die mittel so stark
sehr stark gebunden von dem zuschuss in
den gesundheitsfond über die gkv auch
das ist eine intensive diskussion der
schätzerkreis ist ja zum ergebnis
gekommen dass wir 2023 mit einem defizit
von 17 milliarden euro rechnen müssen
dass wir fühlen müssen das war vor der
inflation das war auch vor der
energiekrise also das wird mit
sicherheit nicht weniger werden und
diese dieses defizit wächst bis 2026
laut dieser zahlen von damals eher auf
30 milliarden euro an und jetzt haben
wir in der diskussion einen vorschlag
von innenminister sowie den
bundeszuschuss noch einmal um zwei
milliarden euro erhöhen dann auf 16,5
milliarden euro und nochmal eine
milliarde euro darlehen geben um dieses
defizit im nächsten jahr auszugleichen
aber ich glaube uns ist allen klar dass
das konzept das jetzt vorliegt mit den
nutzen der reserven aus den
krankenkassen nur luftholen bedeuten
kann wir brauchen echte strukturreformen
brauchen diskussion über diese
strukturreform die müssen jetzt auch
angegangen werden und da erwarte ich
natürlich auch lösungsvorschläge aus dem
ministerium
aber ich denke dass ihn auch viele
anderen betroffen denn der weg kann
nicht sein am ende dass dieses problem
über noch einen höheren bundeszuschuss
gelöst werden soll
herr minister sie haben die
digitalisierung angesprochen von der wir
uns auch große kostenentlastungen
entlastungen erwarten aber es geht auch
um die frage zum beispiel im
krankenhausbereich um das thema
krankenhausinvestitionen und auch da
findet ihr aktuell eine sehr intensive
und sehr spannende debatte von seiten
der länder länder gesundheitsminister
statt ich will einfach mal in erinnerung
gerufen es gibt schon seit längerem ein
bericht des bundesrechnungshofes der
feststellt dass die länder über jahre
jährlich bis zu fünf milliarden euro zu
wenig in die krankenhäuser in dieses
land investieren
das führt natürlich zu einem schlechten
stand bei der digitalisierung das führt
zu schlechten arbeitsabläufen weil der
allbekannten haus strukturen haben und
es führt eben auch dazu dass wir keine
attraktiven arbeitsbedingungen haben
thema fachkräfte man es führt aber auch
dazu dass die gebäudesubstanz schlecht
ist und das fällt uns jetzt in den
aktuellen krisen natürlich noch mal auf
die füße veraltete energiezentralen
schlechte gebäudehüllen führen zu stark
steigenden energiekosten und deshalb
habe ich wohl noch einmal erwähnt herr
minister die spannen diese aktuelle
diskussion sind die gleichen minister
die länderminister die über jahre zu
wenig für ihr gesundheitssystem für ihre
aufgabenstellung getan haben melden sich
presse mit großem getöse vor allem wir
mine heimat minister aus bayern ja und
schiebt dem bund die verantwortung zu
die länder haben über jahre geschlafen
deshalb bremste die krankenhäuser mit
großen defiziten im betriebsbereich und
jetzt von den energiekosten und ich
erwarte dass die länder bereit sind dann
auch dieses defizit zu decken statt
immer nur an der tür des
bundesgesundheitsministers und beim
bundeshaushalt anzuklopfen vielen dank
für ihr auf
karsten klein aus der fdp-fraktion hatte
ein thema zum schluss angesprochen was
uns in den kommenden wochen noch
beschäftigen wird nämlich die
finanzbeziehungen zwischen bund und
ländern sie merken im moment sind die
haushälter und lernen in dieser debatte
über den gesundheitsetat es geht also um
reguläre aspekte dazu auch gesine
lötzsch stellvertretende vorsitzende
linksfraktion
comedyshow davon habe ich gedacht aber
beide hat in der moderator nicht die
frage nach der erhöhung der
krankenkassenbeiträge gestellt und da
sagen wir dass es eine dreiste abzocke
das darf nicht passieren meine damen und
herren und sie selber haben minister
lauterbach wissen doch was die
alternative ist zur erhöhung der
krankenkassenbeiträge seit 18 jahren
mindestens reden sie darüber seit 18
jahren sind sie in einer arbeitsgruppe
der spd zur einführung der
bürgerversicherung ich frage sie wo
bleibt endlich wo sie jetzt minister
sind diese bürgerversicherung
und wenn sie sie werden jetzt sagen sie
sind koalitionstreu aber schauen sie
sich an was so alles nicht passiert ist
was oder passiert ist was nicht im
koalitionsvertrag steht leider reicht
meine zeit nicht dass alles aufzuzählen
meine damen und herren sie könnten ja
zumindest mal anfangen von den ex
kollegen der cdu csu die mit masken
deals millionäre geworden sind das geld
zurückzuholen das wäre ein erster
richtiger schritt zweitens
sie haben angekündigt dass sie von der
pharmaindustrie die in der pandemie
traumgewinne gemacht haben sich geld
zurückholen sie zur kasse bitten aber
auch da sind sich vor der fdp in die
knie gegangen das darf nicht so
weitergehen meine damen und herren
richtig finde ich und das unterstützen
wir ausdrücklich dass sie einen ersten
schritt zur abschaffung der
fallpauschalen unternommen haben die
fallpauschalen wand von vornherein eine
falsche entscheidung und das jetzt bei
den kinderkliniken anfang ist der
richtige schritt folgen muss die
generelle abschaffung der fallpauschalen
sie wissen doch selber wie die situation
ist viele ärztinnen und ärzte müssen auf
profitorientiert in den krankenhäusern
arbeiten sie leiden darunter es
widerspricht ihrer ihrem berufsethos und
das dürfen wir nicht länger hinnehmen
einsamen und herren welche auswirkung
zum beispiel diese unsäglichen zeit
pauschalen haben konnten sie sich vor
kurzem in der ard-dokumentation wie viel
geld bringt ein frühchen anschauen die
krankenhäuser bekommen von der
krankenkasse mehr geld für eine
frühgeburt als für eine normale geburt
in europa sinkt die zahl der
frühgeburten und in deutschland steigt
sie und dass es doch ergebnis der
profitlogik damit werden die
krankenhäuser erpresst das muss ein ende
haben meine damen und herren
die situation der krankenhäuser ist
dramatisch wir alle sind von
krankenhäusern in unseren wahlkreisen
sicher angeschrieben wurden und da hilft
es nicht jetzt anzukündigen mitten in
der haushaltsdebatte so irgendwann kommt
da etwas sie brauchen jetzt ein
inflationsausgleich das roulette das
karussell mit den ländern hilft nicht
weiter wir müssen die krankenhäuser in
unserem land stabilisieren und retten
und letzter satz ich wiederhole wir
brauchen endlich eine solidarische
bürgerversicherung packen sie's an
dankeschön
gesine lötzsch haushaltspolitische
sprecherin und stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende in der
linksfraktion hier geht es weiter mit
svenja stadler die mitglied im
parlamentarischen begleitgrün
19 pandemie ist und aus der spd fraktion
kommt
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe gäste auf
den tribünen und vor den bildschirm
erst vor wenigen monaten haben wir ja
den haushalt für das
bundesgesundheitsministerium
verabschiedet und es würde an vielen
stellen schon gesagt in der höhe von 64
milliarden euro und ich finde diese
sieben diese 64 milliarden euro um
einmal sehr deutlich auch gezeigt dass
die bundesregierung in besonderen lagen
und in dem fall war es die korona lage
bereit sind etwas zu investieren und
aufzufangen und zu unterstützen und das
haben sie nicht nur damals gezeigt
sondern das zeigen sie in den vielen
krisen die wir jetzt auch haben
und
ehrlich gesagt die situation in
deutschland hat sich durch bewohner
verändert sie hat die welt verändert und
es wurde auch noch mal sehr deutlich
gemacht wo wir ansetzen müssen was wir
verändern müssen vor allen dingen auch
im bereich der gesundheit und ich bin
davon überzeugt dass wir das mit dieser
fortschritt koalition mit der ampel
koalition auch hinbekommen denn wir
reden nicht sondern wir backen ansetzen
und mit dem minister an der spitze geht
das sehr gut
[Applaus]
sind das noch total spannend sind auf
der familie aus gesehen auf der rechten
seite dann immer um geduld wird und
geärgert machen sie das er hat eine ganz
lange zeit das zu verändern sie haben es
nicht getan jetzt machen wir es
der regierungs und
2013 dann ist er auf den haushalt zu
sprechen und das wurde ja auch schon
gesagt gibt es eine senkung von diesen
64 milliarden auf die 22,1 milliarden
euro und wenn wir uns auch da das
anschaut 2009/10 vor corona zu jetzt
diesen haushalt haben wir eine
steigerung um 6,8 milliarden und das
zeigt dass es uns wichtig ist etwas zu
verändern und diese herausforderung die
wir haben die werden ja nicht weniger
gottes willen und auch die anstrengungen
werden nicht weniger weil wir wollen ja
etwas verändern mit aller kraft und
macht und vor diesem hintergrund ist es
aber wichtig dass wir sagen wir müssen
mehr handeln aber genau da wo es
notwendig ist und richtig ist mit mehr
qualität und eben doch effizienz und
wenn man sich dann im gesundheitsbereich
im ganzen angriff das ganze
gesundheitssystem wie viel geld da drin
steckt dann reden wir bei einem
dreistelligen milliardenbereich und wenn
wir uns das anschauen und das dass wir
ein modernes gesundheitssystem haben
wollen dann bin ich davon überzeugt dass
wir das hinbekommen und zwar nicht zu
also dass wir es hinbekommen ohne die
patientinnen und patienten zu belasten
und ohne auch dieses personal zu
belasten wir bekommen das hin es gibt
andere aktionäre beziehungsweise
protagonisten die dann ein wenig leiden
werden wir müssen wir alle strukturen
abschaffen und was wir auch machen
müssen ist dass wir es gemeinsam
geschafft mit sämtlichen akteuren des
gesundheitswesen aber auch mit den
bundesländern und auch natürlich mit dem
bund und der bundes bereit dazu seine
seine sehr begrenzten finanzmittel zur
verfügung zu stellen und auch der
verantwortung gerecht zu werden und ich
freue mich wenn alle daran sich
beteiligen der minister hat angesprochen
meine beiden funktionären gesprochen
digitalisierung haben wir vor knapp 20
jahren beschlossen und jetzt ist es
endlich zeit nach 20 jahren auch mit
dieser digitalisierung die erfolge
herbeizuführen auch im gesundheitswesen
wir haben ist weil drei milliarden
bisher investiert und diese
digitalisierung die chancen prozesse zu
vereinfachen und sie auch tatsächlich
flexibler zu gestalten und zu
beschleunigen und das nicht nur eine
lustige fix zukunftsidee ist das habe
ich mir angucken können ich war ein
schritt dorf niedersachsen natürlich das
beste bundesland elfer sage ich ihnen
und dort ist ist die gesundheitsregion
euregio die zeigt wie es funktioniert
wenn sämtliche akteure aus dem gesinnt
gesundheitswesen zusammenstehen wenn
krankenkassen dabei sind wenn
unternehmen zusammen stehen und auch
juristen und da ist das rezept und auch
die epa überhaupt gar keine
zukunftsmusik mehr da wird es umgesetzt
und der wird daran gearbeitet
herausforderungen anzunehmen und nicht
so kosten nein sondern wie schaffen wir
das gemeinsam und das ist dann auch der
erfolgsschlüssel in dieser region bei
diesen protagonisten bei dieser
gemeinschaft geht es nicht
gewinnmaximierung zu agieren sondern an
der sache zu erkämpfen zu agieren und
eben den menschen im mittelpunkt zu
haben dann
[Applaus]
sehe ich das bei uns auch so dass die
wissenschaft einen erheblichen beitrag
dazu geleistet hat dass wir gut durch
diese corona krise gekommen sind und
jetzt heißt es aber auch die
wissenschaft zu stärken und zwar
besonders in der forschung es ist
wichtig effizient zu forschen und auf
deutsches datenmaterial zurückzugreifen
und deswegen finde ich das sehr gut dass
der minister am wochenende nach israel
fahren will und sich gute beispiele
holen kann und ein guter impulsgeber hat
wie wir es zukünftig auf sehr gute beine
stellen können um die wissenschaft auch
zu unterstützen ein experte
bedeutet das einfach die zehn punkten
mit ressourcen zu haben ein
funktionierendes und gutes
gesundheitssystem stellt eine
gesellschaftliche ressource da die es
nachhaltig zu gestalten gibt und wissen
sie hierzu müssen wir die prävention
stärken und auch die wissensvermittlung
da müssen wir auch investieren
denn viele krankheiten sage ich ihnen
bräuchte es erst werden erst gar nicht
entstehen wenn die willensbildung
beziehungsweise aufklärung auch die
prävention gut
visa markt nicht nachhaltig so gut
funktioniert dankeschön ich bin ich sehr
dankbar und deshalb bin ich sehr dankbar
auch in dem fall dass wir darüber
gesprochen haben in form von
gesundheitskosten aber auch die
digitalisierung in form von apps gibt es
viele möglichkeiten denn dadurch gelingt
es uns eine zugangsbedingungen zu
präventionsprogramm zu schaffen und auch
zur gesundheitsversorgung die alle
menschen mitnehmen denn es gibt
unterschiedliche menschen das wissen sie
selber mit den unterschiedlichsten
voraussetzungen sie müssen alle
gleichzeitig die möglichkeit haben
teilzuhaben an der gesundheitlichen
versorgung und prävention und der fokus
muss auch in zukunft sehr viel stärker
auf dem sozialen faktoren liegen denn
sie wissen selber unterschiedliche
soziale hintergründe und ja auch
unterschiedliche lebensweisen haben
einen erheblichen einfluss auf die
gesundheit des einzelnen menschen das
ist nichts neues aber jetzt heißt es
dass diese erkenntnis die wir haben
endlich auch umzusetzen in maßnahmen
also was will ich im großen und ganzen
sagen wir haben einen guten
regierungsentwurf bekommen mit mit
die höchste klar sie kennen auch keine
guten regierungs und würde das weiß ich
aus dem gesundheitsministerium ich weiß
dass ich habe nämlich jetzt einen guten
entwurf
und wir haben an der an einer anderen
stelle sicherlich noch möglichkeiten
ihnen ein stückchen besser zu machen mit
impulsen die wir jetzt im laufe der zeit
auch von unseren gesundheitspolitikern
sicherlich bekommen dann werden wir in
die beratungen gehen und am ende werden
wir den besten
regierungsentwurf verabschieden nach
braunau vielen dank
eine ziemlich optimistische svenja
stadler die unter anderem mitglied im
parlamentarischen begleitung cupid 19
pandemie ist im deutschen bundestag
nächster redner ist michael henrich aus
der unionsfraktion noch in deren
konstruktion muss man sagen und noch im
bundestag im frühjahr wird der
ausscheiden aus dem parlament
und dann
zu meinem vater verwandt haben wechseln
kolleginnen und kollegen wir beraten
heute in einzelne 15 und als wir im
letzten jahr noch 64 milliarden euro im
gesundheitshaus halt eingestellt hatten
hatten wir die hoffnung dass wir im jahr
2023 entspannung haben und in der tat
schlägt sich das in den haushaltszahlen
nieder mit einem etat von 22 milliarden
euro wir nähern uns damit schrittweise
dem vor
corona haushalt und ich bin ihnen
dankbar herr minister lauterbach dass
sie heute in ihrer rede anders als in
der letzten haushaltsdebatte eine
gesundheitspolitische agenda aufgezeigt
haben sie am vier themen punkte
angesprochen pflege krankenhaus
digitalisierung und kiosk und erlaubten
sie mir dass ich zu allen vier punkten
ein kurzes statement mache beim thema
pflege
ist es glaubt ganz ganz wichtig dass wir
in den mittelpunkt stellen das thema
personal und da geht es nicht nur um
bezahlung sondern da geht es um
verlässlichkeit da geht es auch um
entbürokratisierung
dass wir in den mittelpunkt stellen die
zu pflegenden die heute oftmals auf
einem verschiebebahnhof sind zwischen
krankenhaus und pflegeeinrichtungen
fliegende
angehörige beim thema krankenhaus es
glaubt ganz ganz wichtig was sie herr
klein angesprochen haben dass wir das
thema dualistische finanzierung wieder
stärker in den mittelpunkt stellen und
auch etwas einfordern von den ländern
das thema
digitalisierung da ist mein wunsch in
mein appell an sie dass wir das auch als
chance begreifen für den standort kam
ich dann erinnern dass der
winter professor im bereich künstliche
intelligenz professor schmidhuber vor
fünf jahren mal in der faz einen artikel
hat und gesagt hat wir haben die meisten
daten in deutschland wir haben
unglaublich viel potenzial beim thema
kam ich bin froh dass im haushalt 45
millionen eingestellt sind aber
kommunizieren sie das besser und geben
sie entsprechende signale an die
gesundheitswirtschaft kritisch sehe ich
das thema kioske das gebe ich ganz offen
zu weil ich denke dass wir genug akteure
in der versorgung haben der kollege
müller hat die hausärzte angesprochen
die haben apotheker wir haben
unabhängige patientenberatung
pflegestützpunkte und ich glaube es ist
wichtiger dass wir die miteinander
verzahnen
und sehr geehrter herr minister
lauterbach die wichtigste frage haben
sie offen gelassen wie
finanzieren wir das alles das ist heute
eine letzte rede als
gesundheitspolitiker nach 20 jahren
und ich hatte jedes jahr die hoffnung
dass wir diese grundlegende finanzreform
irgendwann hinbekommen ich bin dem
kollegen müller dankbar dass er diese
woche in der faz ein namensartikel hatte
wurden als ganz wichtige zentrale themen
angesprochen hat wie geht es weiter mit
der steuerfinanzierung wie bekommen wir
eine faire finanzierung der tausch
beträge bei den arbeitslosengeld zwei
empfängern ein thema das eigentlich
diese koalition versprochen hat aber
keinen niederschlag findet in diesem
haushaltsentwurf von meinen wunsch und
mein appell wäre klar vor dem
hintergrund lieber klein was sie sehr
deutlich gemacht haben dass wir eine
echte grundlegende
strukturreform brauchen dass wir
vielleicht in dieser längst und 60 noch
zusammenfinden wie das damals bei
lahnstein
dazwischen neben herrn seehofer und dem
herrn drexler als die gemeinsamen
kompromiss auf den weg gebracht haben
dass wir in den schweren zeiten in dem
wir momentan sind
zumindestens in dem bereich der
sozialversicherung den menschen eine
perspektive
klarheit geben das wäre mein wunsch den
ich nach 20 jahren habe ich werde nicht
mehr erleben aber es wäre schön wenn ich
den in anderer position begleiten könnte
herzlichen dank ich möchte die
gelegenheit nutzen
mich bei allen kolleginnen und kollegen
ganz herzlich zu bedanken für die gute
vertrauensvolle zusammenarbeit ich
glaube wir haben eine besondere
atmosphäre im gesundheitsausschuss und
es hat unsere arbeit geprägt ich möchte
mich bedanken bei vielen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern
ob dies bei den abgeordneten ist in den
ausschüssen oder im ministerium die ganz
besonders in den letzten jahren
gefordert waren wie wir samstags
sonntags zweistündige videokonferenzen
hatten fing bei denen die arbeit erst an
auch ein herzliches dankeschön ich werde
an anderer stelle im gesundheitswesen
weiter abend arbeiten und würde mich
freuen wenn ich bei ihnen ein offenes
ohr finder herzlichen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit letzte rede als
gesundheitspolitiker aber hoffentlich
nicht die letzte rede im parlament
herzen
michael hat es selbst gesagt wir hatten
der eingang ist auch schon erwähnt
wechselt im februar zu einem
pharmaverband deshalb wird jetzt nicht
mehr als gesundheitspolitiker reden aber
auch noch nicht aus dem parlament
ausscheiden am pult ist das haupt aus
der fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen
obfrau im gesundheits
die kürzung des etats von 64 milliarden
euro auf die 22 milliarden euro
erscheint im ersten moment sehr
plausibel die kostenintensiveren
ausgaben der letzten jahren zu der
chorakademie werden jetzt wesentlich
zielgerichteter ausgegeben sei es für
die impfstoff beschaffung oder für die
aufklärungskampagnen und ist ein klage
kann er mir ist nicht vorbei und
deswegen ist es gut dass wir hier noch
einmal geld in die hand nehmen
aber die gute gesundheitsversorgung ist
noch wesentlich mehr
gute gesundheitsversorgung gibt
sicherheit sicherheit das sind pflege
benötigt wird sie auch wirklich da ist
sicherheit das in der kinderwunsch
ansteht dann wird die frau eine hebamme
findet man sich keine gedanken machen
muss dass niemand da ist und ängste und
sorgen und bei dieser sicherheit darf
nicht gespart werden
und ich weiß
die haushälterin brauchen sich jetzt die
haare wenn wir als fachpolitiker in dir
unsere wunschliste auspacken wofür wir
alles geld hätten aber im ernst eine
gute und gerechte finanzierte
gesundheitsversorgung ist kein nice to
have und das ist nichts was sie mal eben
aus der portokasse bezahlen ist ein
grundpfeiler unserer gesellschaft und
wir wissen alle es gibt wichtige
projekte die wir umsetzen müssen und die
kaum auffindbar sind ich gebe meine
geburtshilfe zu den hebammen die
umsetzung des nationalen
gesundheitsziele und haid rund um die
geburt die eins zu eins betreuung durch
hebammen während der geburt die hebammen
geleiteten kreißsaal die wir aufbauen
wollen oder die vergütung für
angestellte hebammen in den kliniken die
die nach wie vor sorge machen wollen und
ehrlich gesagt es ist nicht nur die
geburtshilfe wir können auch weiter
schauen die suchtprävention die
entstigmatisierung von psychischen
erkrankungen aber auch die entlastung
der reha und mutter kind kliniken das
sind punkte die alle finanzielle mittel
brauche
gesundheit ist eine wichtige wichtige
aufgabe und deshalb dürfen wir uns
selber nicht limitieren und ist die
aufgabe aller die hier verantwortung
haben auch ernsthafte lösungsvorschläge
zu machen wie wir das ganze finanzieren
können und gesellschaftliche
herausforderung begegnen können und
lebensrealitäten von menschen verbessern
können und ja wir
leben in krisenzeiten aber es ist keine
option dass wir uns aus diesen krisen
herausfahren und damit maßgeblich in
kauf nehmen dass sich die
gesundheitsversorgung hier in diesem
land verschlechtert und für die menschen
denn wenn die ernsthaft daran
interessiert sind wenn wir ernsthaft
daran interessiert sind die
gesundheitsversorgung auch zu verbessern
brauchen wir geld und dann müssen wir
darüber nachdenken ob das ewige sparen
der richtige weg ist oder ob wir nicht
die schulter noch mehr belasten können
die auch mehr tragen können ich bin froh
dass wir am anfang des parlamentarischen
haushaltsverfahren sind und unsere
aufgabe ist es jetzt eben auch
handlungsspielräume zu erkennt
vielleicht auch lücken zu erkennen und
diese auch zu nutzen das erwarte ich von
uns ein und ich freue mich darauf vielen
dank
[Applaus]
jetzt bricht martin sichert für die fdp
für die afg fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
15 euro bekommt jeder arzt wenn er packt
ovid von pfizer verschreibt 15 euro pro
verschreibung um die gewinne eines
pharmakonzerns zu steigern während
millionen menschen nicht mehr wissen wie
sie essen strom oder gas bezahlen sollen
die prioritätensetzung dieser regierung
ist völlig falsch
so wie sie mit der gasanlage
internationale großkonzerne und deren
aktionäre finanzieren genauso versorgen
sie in der gesundheitspolitik die
pharmakonzerne mit milliarden karl
lauterbach präsentiert sich als pfizer
minister für deren medikamente ständig
über seine kanäle bewirbt deutschland
braucht endlich wieder eine
gesundheitspolitik und keine pharma
politik
die gesundheitspolitik besteht übrigens
nicht nur aus döner wir haben zum
beispiel an den massiven mangel an
pflegekräften und fachärzten viele
menschen müssen monatelang auf termine
warten monate die oftmals zwischen leben
und tod entscheiden diese toten sind
karl lauterbach und der bundesregierung
offensichtlich egal stattdessen kümmert
man sich lieber darum wie man wieder ab
herbst mit dem infektionsschutzgesetz
die freiheitsrechte der bürger
einschränken kann die änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes hat keine
wissenschaftliche basis sie ist einfach
nur ein weiterer deutscher sonderweg
diese ganzen sonderwege die im ausland
als politischer extremismus deutschlands
empfunden werden müssen endlich aufhören
weil sie nur schaden anrichten
kein anderes relevantes land steigt aus
der atomkraft aus kein anderes
relevantes lanz testreihen auf solar-
und windenergie kein anderes relevantes
land setzt auf unbegrenzte zuwanderung
kein anderes relevantes land
sanktioniert rohstoffe die für es selbst
lebenswichtig sind nahezu alle anderen
länder haben corona für beendet erklärt
aber deutschland will nun die maßnahme
noch einmal verschärfen wir die afg
vertreten bei corona wie auch in allen
politischen bereichen das was sie 90
prozent der länder weltweit politischer
konsens ist wir sind der mainstream und
die politik dieser regierung ist
extremistisch
[Applaus]
und von der union braucht dazu gar
niemand zu grinsen wenn sie haben mit
dieser politik schließlich angefangen
deutliches zeichen des extremismus der
regierung ist übrigens auch dass den
abgeordneten wichtige studienergebnisse
vorenthalten werden nur weil diese
ergebnisse zeigen dass das
infektionsschutzgesetz überflüssig ist
die studien sind ja trotzdem
durchgesickert heute früh sie zeigen 95
prozent der menschen haben antikörper
corona ist vorbei hören sie auf die
menschen weiter zu gängeln
die schäden der maßnahmen müssen
schließlich die bürger mit ihrem hart
verdienten geld und mit ihrer kostbaren
gesundheit bezahlen beenden wir die
politik der deutschen sonderwege und
kümmern wir uns endlich um die echten
probleme im gesundheitswesen das wäre
nicht nur besser für die gesundheit der
menschen sondern es werde auch deutlich
weniger geld erfordern
das rückgrat jetzt das wort für die fdp
fraktion
[Applaus]
war übrigens pflege unternehmerin vor
ihrer zeit im bundestag
frau präsidentin werte kolleginnen und
kollegen bei manchen regen ist man dort
doch froh wenn sie zum ende finden ich
möchte hier wieder zur sachpolitik
zurückkehren mein kollege der kasten
kleinen der hat ja bereits erläutert
welche großen themen und bereiche im
haushalt des gesundheitsministeriums aus
liberaler sicht besonders wichtig sind
und unser gesundheitspolitischer
sprecher andrew ullmann wird später auch
noch weitere nennen mir ist vor allem
wichtig dass wir auch die
innovationskraft des gesundheitssektors
immer mitdenken mit fördern und
essenzielle branche nicht einschränken
denn darüber sind wir uns ja alle einig
unser gesundheitssystem muss
zukunftsfest werden durch
digitalisierung durch verwaltungs abbau
durch innovationsförderung und dort wo
nötig auch durch paradigmenwechsel
bürgerinnen und bürger patientinnen und
patienten und die dauerhaft an
demografische herausforderungen
ausgerichtete leistungsfähigkeit unseres
systems die müssen im mittelpunkt stehen
und da sind vorsorge und prävention auf
die klügere die günstigere und damit die
nachhaltige wahl als nachsorge und
schadensbegrenzung
deshalb wird die kolleginnen und
kollegen möchte ich als sucht und
drogenpolitische sprecherin meiner
fraktion hier noch das augenmerk auf
einen teil des haushalts lenken denen
wir uns noch mal etwas genauer anschauen
sollten in der einführung zum einzelplan
15 heißt es ziel der drogen- und
suchtpolitik ist die reduzierung des
konsums legaler und illegaler drogen
sowie die vermeidung der drogen und
sucht bedingten probleme in unserer
gesellschaft
diesem ziel haben sich die ampel
koalitionäre verschrieben und unter
dieser vorgabe nämlich gesundheitsschutz
und prävention betreiben wir das
anliegen der legalisierung von cannabis
zu genuss zwecken für erwachsene und
dabei handelt es sich um nichts weniger
als einen dringend notwendigen
paradigmenwechsel in der cannabis
politik in deutschland
weg von der position hin zu einem
aufgeklärten umgang mit cannabis nach
erfolgter legalisierung aber das gilt
auch für die präventionsarbeit in bezug
auf alkohol nikotin medikamenten und
tablettensucht für hilfe für kinder aus
suchtbelasteten familien
aber auch im bereich des marketings und
der suchtberatung
denn das alles wird in auf die
vermeidung von drogen und sucht
bedingten problemen die prävention muss
dabei aktuelle probleme bedarfsgerecht
und flexibel aufgreifen so wie auch
darauf reagieren können wie zum beispiel
auf probleme die auch durch die korona
pandemie verstärkt wurden der
paradigmenwechsel der muss sich daher
auch im haushalt widerspiegeln
umso wichtiger ist es dass wir in diesen
titeln ausreichend mittel bereitstellen
und unsere anstrengungen verstetigen
denn jeder hier angesetzte euro ist eine
investition in die zukunft unseres
systems einem gesundheitssystem das auf
prävention und vorsorge setzt und damit
auch bei vielleicht vorübergehend
höheren ausgaben am ende die
nachhaltigere und haushalterisch
zukunftsweisende strategie ist
uns immer noch als ich 20 17 in den
bundestag kam habe ich mich gefreut wie
jetzt habe ich die chance etwas zu
machen auch wenn man der opposition
waren und hatte auch gehofft dass wir
mit einem unionsgeführten
gesundheitsminister sich da etwas ändert
aber es hat sich nichts geändert das ist
alles sehr schade
stattdessen wenn wir darüber diskutieren
der bund muss zahlen wir wissen wie es
funktioniert auf länderebene ich kombi
herrn klein auch aus bayern und ich muss
auch sagen es läuft auch in bayern nicht
vernünftig und die länder machen sich
wirklich an schlanken fuß in der
krankenhausfinanzierung auch jetzt in
der krise machen sich die länder einen
schlanken fuß ob jetzt in thüringen oder
auch in bayern und anderen bundesländern
und da erwarte ich eigentlich viel mehr
denn wir brauchen
wir brauchen ein besseres system
wir brauchen und das können wir jetzt
machen in der ampelkoalition bei wir
haben die leute zusammen wir sind
motiviert ich kann mich nur sehr gut
erinnern koalitionsverhandlungen und
diese fortschritts koalition ist der weg
auch dahin im einzelplan 15 zeigt der
weg dahin zusammen mit unseren
gesundheitsminister und den kollegen
kollegen hier in der koalition in die
ersten schritte sind jetzt gemacht
worden
krankenhaus kommission ist eingerichtet
worden ähnlich wird die
notfallversorgung besser bessere füße
gestellt in deutschland die
kinderheilkunde bin auch bessere füße
gestellt auch die geburtshilfe wieder
besseren physischen das ist forschern
meine damen und herren und nicht hacker
bereits wohnzimmer hören
ich bin auch froh dass waren
digitalisierungs minister haben der
volker wissing der hat jetzt eine
digitale strategie der bundesregierung
nach vorne gebracht das heißt endlich
haben wir digitalisierungs fahrplan und
gesundheitswesen das war längst
überfällig da hat die union vier jahre
oder manche sagen auch 16 jahren
geschlafen da ist auch nichts passiert
aber wir machen das wir sind eine
fortschritte zu erkennen dass auch
wir stellen den menschen in den
mittelpunkt unserer politik das haben
wir als menschen die jetzt auch im
gesundheitswesen gearbeitet haben gilt
auch unsere prämisse in der politik
selbst das haben wir jetzt auch gezeigt
auch in der pandemie krise wie wir da
auch zusammen agieren können wir uns ist
auch klar dass diese verantwortung nicht
nur in deutschland gilt sondern auch
weltweit und deshalb finde ich gut dass
wir als koalition die globale gesundheit
nicht nur politisch angehen sondern auch
praktisch mit unterstützung der bh oden
kollegin ich heute hat sie auch schon
erlebt und ich wollte es auch als
vorsitzende des unterausschusses globale
gesundheit hier explizit werden das ist
auch fortschritte damen und herren
verstehen dass hier gemeinsam zum
schluss wir fortschritt auch in der
globalen gesundheit gestalten werden und
bedanke mich für die aufmerksamkeit
denn pohlmann aus der fdp fraktion auch
er arzt ich hab's eingangs gesagt zwei
ärzte kommt übrigens nach tobel seien
sie gespannt und der ausdruck heißt
natürlich innere medizin schicken
medizin wir etwas vom innenausschuss war
wird gerade am pult dietrich monstadt
aus der unionsfraktion auch er ist
mitglied im gesundheitsausschuss liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen werte damen
meine herren die parlamentarische
sommerpause hat uns allen deutlich
gezeigt es in allen bereichen chaos in
der regierung gerade und vor allem in
der gesundheitspolitik
spiegelbild auch dafür ist dieser
vorgelegte haushalt vor der
gesundheitsetat schrumpft auf 22
milliarden euro ohne dass es ein konzept
gibt dass das gesundheitssystem die
anstehenden probleme oder gar die folgen
der korona pandemie angeht herr kollege
man dies als fortschritt zu bezeichnen
da fehlt mir einfach die fantasie
dass der zuschuss meine damen und herren
für die krankenkassen nach der pandemie
von 30 milliarden wieder auf 14,5
milliarden euro zurückgeführt wird zeigt
wie konzeptlos bei der stabilisierung
der finanzen im gesundheitssektor
vorangegangen wird der minister ein
problem sind die umsetzungsfristen für
maßnahmen des krankenhaus zukunftsfonds
bereits 2020 hat die union zusammen mit
der spd ein milliardenschweres
förderprogramm aufgelegt um den
digitalen ausbau der krankenhäuser
voranzutreiben doch mittlerweile
belasten die umsetzungsfristen unsere
krankenhäuser aber erst 125 sind einige
leistungen sanktions beachtet das führt
dazu meine damen und herren dass diese
projekte erst gar nicht angegangen
werden dazu kommen galoppierende strom
und gaspreise die unsere krankenhäuser
ist hier wiederholt angesprochen worden
vor enorme finanzielle herausforderung
stellen eine antwort darauf gibt der
haushaltsentwurf nicht aber herr
minister sie haben heute angekündigt die
wollen dort helfe zwar angekündigt aber
wie werden sie dort beim wort nehmen
meine damen und herren jedes mal wenn
ich hier stehe frage ich sie herr
minister was passiert mit der umsetzung
der nationalen diabetes strategie jedes
mal muss ich sie auf die dringlichkeit
dieses themas hinweisen ohne dass
irgendetwas passiert sinnvolle
initiativen gibt es bereits wie zb eine
nationale diabetes datenbank die dazu
beitragen könnte unter und
überversorgung in einzelnen regionen
oder patientengruppen zu identifizieren
das würde zu einer kurs bestrafung und
effizienteren finanzierung von
behandlungen führen
daten aus israel zeigen uns dass sie
eine datenbank moderne
diabetesversorgung unterstützen kann der
minister hier anstehender besuch in
israel gibt ihnen die chance sich dort
auch zu diesem thema zu informieren
meine damen und herren auch die damen ja
die positiv entwickeln sich alarmierend
in deutschland sind es fast 60 prozent
der erwachsenen ca 30 prozent der jungen
und 27 prozent der mädchen die
übergewichtig sind und adipös sind jedes
sechste kind in deutschland ist seit der
korona pandemie dicker geworden eine
ganze generation ist von diesem
übergewicht betroffen experten und ärzte
mahnen dass es sich um eine nie
dagewesene gewichtszunahme handelt herr
minister richtige prävention
vernünftige präventionspolitik liegt in
ihren händen mein appell an die
bundesregierung handeln sie schnell
effektiv und nachhaltig handeln sie
jetzt
die inaktivität dieser regierung macht
mir und uns auch an anderer stelle große
sorgen das wichtige thema der eu
medizinprodukte verordnung mdr muss von
der regierung deutlich ernsthafter
angegangen werden ich begrüße
ausdrücklich die im juli 22 begonnenen
dialog prozess bei der implementierung
dieser verordnung doch dialog alleine
reicht nicht aus wir brauchen lösungen
ansonsten verlieren wir geschätzt zehn
prozent insbesondere der kleinen und
mittelständischen unternehmen und ca 40
prozent der zugelassenen medizinprodukte
die lage ist dramatisch
wir das heißt alle betroffenen patienten
an minder oder unternehmen brauchen
jetzt entscheidungen mit tech
unternehmen müssen jetzt entscheidungen
darüber treffen welche produkte am markt
gehalten werden können und welche nicht
jedes produkt denks auf dem markt
genommen wird steht für die versorgung
auf dauer nicht mehr zur verfügung meine
damen und herren dieser haushaltsentwurf
ist eindeutig ein rückschritt vor allem
in den von mir angesprochenen bereichen
wir legen ihnen entschieden herzlichen
dank
dietrich monstadt war das aus der
unionsfraktion im gesundheitsausschuss
und der nächste redner ist jetzt nicht
erst im klassischen sinne aber doktor
med der neurobiologie
christophsbads es aus der spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen die
herausforderungen der letzten jahre wie
der chor oder pandemie sowie der
russische angriffskrieg auf die ukraine
haben zu einer schwierigen politischen
gesellschaftlichen und wirtschaftlichen
lage geführt infolgedessen sehen wir uns
mit einer angespannten
haushaltssituation des bundes und der
sozialversicherungsträger konfrontiert
so steht die gesetzliche
krankenversicherung die tragende säule
unseres solidarsystems unter einem
enormen finanziellen druck bereits seit
2009 10 schreibt die rote zahlen ein
anhaltender reformstau hat zu einem
auseinanderklaffen von einnahmen und
ausgaben und folglich zu einem
milliardenschweren defizit geführt
allein im nächsten jahr fehlen ihr
mindestens 17 milliarden euro verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen diese zahl
macht einmal mehr deutlich es herrscht
akuter handlungsbedarf
trotz erschwerter rahmenbedingungen
bekennen wir uns als fortschritts
koalition ich zitiere zu einer stabilen
und verlässlichen finanzierung der
gesetzlichen krankenversicherung zur
kurzfristigen deckung der finanzlücke
steht das vom bundeskabinett nun
beschlossene gkv finanzierung
finanzstabilisierungs gesetz unter
anderem vor beitrags reserven von kassen
und gesundheitsfonds heranzuziehen
darlehen zu vergeben und letztendlich
auch zusatzbeiträge in einem moderaten
rahmen zu erhöhen für die spd fraktion
ist dabei maßgeblich die lasten auf
mehrere schultern zu verteilen in dem
der pharmaindustrie werden auch
ärztinnen zahnärztinnen apotheken und
andere ihren beitrag zur stabilisierung
der gesetzlichen krankenversicherung
leisten müssen für meine fraktion kann
ich ferner perspektivisch erklären dass
wir die im koalitionsvertrag
festgehaltene regelhafte dynamisierung
des bundeszuschusses sowie höhere
beiträge für die bezieherinnen
hier von arbeitslosengeld 2 aus
steuermitteln auch weiterhin avisieren
wir streben eine ausgewogene und
nachhaltige finanzierung aus
steuerzuschüssen
effizienzsteigerungen einbeziehung
weiterer einkommensarten sowie auch eine
anhebung der beitragsbemessungsgrenze an
und hier freue ich mich dass nach jahren
der blockade um nun die union in der
opposition offenbar ihr ich sags mal so
sozialdemokratisches herz entdeckt hat
und sich genau diesen forderungen
angeschlossen hatte die lektüre der taz
herr müller hat mir wirklich sehr
gefallen ich freue mich sie jetzt auch
an unserer seite zu wissen
verehrte kolleginnen kollegen auch wir
halten nachhaltige strukturreformen im
gesundheitssystem für unumgänglich so
zum beispiel in der
krankenhauslandschaft die notwendigkeit
eines strukturwandels wird mittlerweile
auch von krankenhaus stelle bestätigt
erste reformschritte für eine moderne
und bedarfsgerechte
krankenhausversorgung wurden mit der
einberufung der regierungskommission
herr kollege und man hat es schon gesagt
gemacht
mittlerweile hat diese erste vorschläge
für die bereiche pädiatrie
kinderchirurgie und geburtshilfe
vorgelegt weitere sondern folge und dann
grundlage der krankenhaus reform werden
die ab dem jahr 2023 umgesetzt werden
sollen während der bund also erste
schritte für den strukturwandel
unternimmt müssen auch alle es ist
gesagt worden bundesländer ihre
investitions verpflichtungen nachkommen
niedersachsen beispielsweise wird dieser
verpflichtung bereits jetzt gerächt
neben einem wegweisenden neuen
krankenhausgesetz stellen
ministerpräsident weil und
gesundheitsministerin behrens weitere
210 millionen euro für krankenhäuser zur
verfügung
das ist ein starkes signal für eine
stabile gesundheitsversorgung und ich
hoffe sehr dass weitere bundesländer
diesem beispiel folgen werden
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen ich
komme abschließend zum schluss und fasse
zusammen
auch unter schwierigen finanziellen
bedingungen wird sich die spd fraktion
weiterhin entschieden für ein
solidarisches
sozialverträgliches und gerechtes
gesundheitssystem für alle einsetzen das
getreu der losung unseres kanzlers
niemanden zurück lässt weder
hilfsbedürftige noch beschäftigte
herzlichen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
und damit kommen wir vom doktor mir der
noro bionik zu einem studierten
anästhesist und intensivmediziner
jetzt ist er vorsitzender im
haushaltsausschuss war der letzte
kanzleramtsminister der letzten
merkel-regierung helge braun gelegen wir
beraten dass es eben mehrfach gesagt
worden ein entwurf des haushalts für
gesundheit der von über 60 auf 22
millionen sich reduziert und das ist
überall da auch sachgerecht wo die hohen
aufwendungen der vergangenheit durch die
korona pandemie inzwischen weggefallen
sind aber sehr lauterbach haben wir
davon gesprochen dass es ihr ziel ist
die krankenhäuser zum beispiel in ihrer
belastung zur and economy sieren und
wenn man diesen haushalt hineinschaut
sieht man der kostendruck in der
gesetzlichen krankenversicherung wird im
nächsten jahr massiv steigen und die
besonderen 70 milliarden in die
krankenhäuser im letzten drei jahren
zusätzlich bekommen haben sind allesamt
gestrichen das heißt in der konsequenz
dass die krankenhäuser die heute noch in
ihrem leistungsniveau etwa unter 20 also
über etwas über 80 prozent von dem
niveau sind was vor corona war haben 20
prozent weniger leistungsfähigkeit
insbesondere durch personalprobleme sie
haben die höheren energiekosten
sie haben zusätzliche personalausgaben
in zukunft auch durch ihr gesetz was sie
im august vorgestellt haben und das
alles führt dazu dass die krankenhäuser
dass wir insolvenzen werden und sie
lösen es nicht dadurch dass sie jetzt
eine struktur reform auf den weg bringen
sondern sie lösen es über kostendruck
und viele menschen die heute noch gerne
im krankenhaus arbeiten
wir werden diese lust in den nächsten
jahren verlieren weil sie nicht reformen
machen sondern weil sie versuchen das
problem über den kostendruck zu lösen
ein thema was uns in den letzten
haushaltsberatungen hier sehr intensiv
beschäftigt hat und auch von karsten
klein und fischotter hier angesprochen
wir uns war das thema der bürger test
und wir haben neben der tatsache dass
wir es richtig fanden im
haushaltsausschuss dass die länder
stärker in die finanzierung eingebunden
werden ein sehr deutlicher hinweis des
bundesrechnungshofs gehabt dass die
kontrolle des missbrauchs dieser bürger
tests verbessert werden muss und da
haben wir ihnen eine maßgabe gegeben im
haushaltsausschuss dass sie sich darum
kümmern sollen und dann ist was ziemlich
skurril ist passiert eines abends im
fernsehen sagen sie das problem ist
gelöst
nächsten morgen wieder spricht ihnen die
kassenärztliche vereinigung dann setzten
sich mit der kv zusammen die kv ist die
institution in deutschland die das thema
qualitätssicherung und ausgabenkontrolle
im gesundheitswesen als zentrale aufgabe
hat mit weit über 10.000 beschäftigten
dann sagen sie der kv zu und akzeptieren
dass die sagen sie können diese
kontrolle mit ihrem gesamten apparat
nicht wahrnehmen und kommen dann auf die
idee dem robert-koch-institut den
virologen den labor medizinern den
immunologen die dort strukturell
anfragen der pandemie der gesundheit und
des öffentlichen gesundheitswesens
arbeiten denen die ausgabenkontrolle in
die hand zu geben und ich bin ziemlich
sicher damit haben wir das problem nicht
gelöst und wir haben es verschlimmert
und ehrlich gesagt mir so peinlich
gegenüber den experten im paket das wir
ihnen diese aufgabe übertragen haben
nebenbei hatten sie auch angekündigt
dass sie die surveillance also die frage
welche wie das krankheitsgeschehen sich
in der bevölkerung entwickelt
international und national voranbringen
wollen was wir jetzt sehen ist das für
die krankenhaus james über
atemwegserkrankungen sie dem ärger die
sogar die mittel streichen und es ist
auch angeklungen bei mehreren
insbesondere bei ihnen herr ullmann wie
wichtig uns das thema der
internationalen gesundheit der globalen
gesundheit ist und das ist etwas da
haben wir die mittel in der pandemie
hochgefahren aber jeder weiß doch dass
genau diese aufgabe jetzt nicht vorbei
ist sondern eigentlich erst anfängt und
die tatsache dass in diesem haushalt die
mittel glatt halbiert werden gegenüber
dem vorjahresniveau das kann man nicht
damit begründen dass die pandemie vorbei
sondern das heißt die internationale
gesundheit hat in diesem haushalt keine
priorität und ich bin sehr hoffnungsvoll
dass wir die haushaltsberatung nutzen
und da sind wir auch an ihrer seite wenn
die koalition dazu bereit ist dass wir
im bereich globale gesundheit
internationale gesundheit diesen entwurf
grundlegend überarbeiten müssen
viel gesprochen worden dass auch über
die gesetzliche krankenversicherung und
den entwurf des sicherungs gesetzt
karsten klein hat gesagt er gibt uns
einmal luft um sozusagen die reformen
auf den weg zu bringen ich finde dieser
entwurf gibt nicht luft er lässt die
luft raus die mindestreserve bei den
gesetzlichen krankenkassen bin so
abgesenkt dass bei kleinen kassen in der
größenordnung von 3 millionen plus nur
ein bisschen liegt und wenn man weiß
dass zum beispiel bei so einer
erkrankung die spinale atrophie eine
einzeltherapie also ein neuer patient
einer kleinen krankenkassen kosten von
bis zu zwei millionen euro alleine
verursachen kann wird man sehen dass
kleine krankenkassen die plötzlich ein
solches risiko realisiert bekommen dann
in ernste probleme bekommen und dann
wirtschaftlichen schwierigkeiten kommen
weil sie die zusatzbeiträge so erhöhen
müssen dass sie auf der anderen seite
nicht mehr wettbewerbsfähig sind sie
lassen die letzte luft raus ohne eine
strukturelle reform der gkv auf den weg
zu bringen und das ist auch keine gute
nachricht für die zukunft
erst ein kleiner doch angesprochen dass
dieses strukturelle defizit von 17
milliarden in den nächsten jahren auf
wächst auf über 30 milliarden 2
milliarden sind sie bereit zusätzlich
aus dem bundeshaushalt zu decken den
großen anteil müssen die bürgerinnen und
bürgern die arbeitgeber zahlen über die
zusatzbeiträge
was sie aber auch tun ist dass sie aus
dem bundeshaushalt ein darlehen von
einer milliarde zur verfügung stellen
und angesichts eines auf wachsenden
strukturellen defizits frage ich mich
wie soll denn dieses darlehen von den
kassen in zukunft jemals wieder
zurückbezahlt werden sie wissen ganz
genau dass das nicht funktioniert und
deshalb gibt es nur eine einzige
begründung für dieses darlehen es ist
nämlich eigentlich ein verlorener
zuschuss aber sie deklarieren es als
darlehen weil sie es sozusagen als
kleine mogelpackung nicht auf die
schuldenbremse anrechnen wollen und ich
rechne damit sie werden mit diesem tage
um den nächsten jahren weitermachen sie
werden es immer höher machen und sie
werden es nie zurückbekommen und damit
ist es mit klassischen schuhmodell sie
halten die schulden bleiben sie nicht
ein diesen entwurf
helge braun vorsitzender ebenen
haushaltsausschuss des boden des tages
war der vorletzte redner in der debatte
in der ersten beratung des einzel platz
15 das ist der der etat für das
bundesgesundheitsministerium und da ist
jetzt die letzte rednerin linda heitmann
aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
liebe kolleginnen
prävention die medizinische definition
dieses begriffes lautet durch
zielgerichtete maßnahmen krankheiten
vorbeugen und verhindern wir beraten
hier heute den gesundheitsetat und
unsere aufgabe ist es dabei auch
präventiv und vorausschauend zu handeln
mir
ist es in diesem zusammenhang ganz
besonders wichtig auch suchterkrankungen
in unserem land wirklich wirksam zu
verhindern und dafür ausreichend mittel
auch einzuplanen denn wenn wir uns die
ausgangslage hier angucken dann stehen
wir davor dass zum beispiel im bereich
des rauchens wir erfreulicherweise in
deutschland jahrelang zurückgehende
raucherinnen zahlen hatten aber während
der pandemie hat die zahl der
raucherinnen und raucher in deutschland
leider wieder zugenommen und auch beim
thema alkohol müssen wir leider sehen
dass die ersten auswirkungen der
pandemie zeigen menschen die vorher
schon viel getrunken haben haben während
der pandemie meist noch mehr getrunken
und sind häufig sogar in eine
suchterkrankung gerutscht und viele
alkoholkranke menschen die trocken waren
haben auch rückfälle erlitten während
der pandemie ich finde deshalb wir
dürfen wirklich bei der prävention in
diesem bereich nicht sparen denn jeder
euro nachdem wir hier investieren der
zahlt sich hinterher auch doppelt aus
und ich beschäftige mich im
gesundheitsausschuss noch mit einer
weiteren folge der pandemie nämlich mit
dem phänomen von long beach
beziehungsweise post gobiet denn viele
menschen in diesem land betrifft das
thema einer kuh wie 19 erkrankung leider
deutlich länger als sie die zwei striche
auf ihrem test sehen wir sehen das
phänomen das von schlimm
lungenerkrankung bis hin zu starken
erschöpfungssymptomen wirklich die
infektion mit 19 ihre spuren hinterlässt
und deshalb finde ich auch das muss sich
in unserem haushalt widerspiegeln wir
müssen hier in forschung investieren um
zu lang ovid genauere aussagen zu
kriegen zielgerichtet medikamente
entwickeln zu können und auch die
behandlungen darauf auszurichten dass
diesen menschen gut geholfen werden kann
2022 haben wir damit im haushalt schon
angefangen und geld für die erforschung
von longkou mit medikamenten eingestellt
das müssen wir 2023 auch fortführen und
in allen haushaltsetat gucken dass wir
vernünftig an dieses phänomen herangehen
weitere themen die mir in meinem bereich
wichtig sind für die reicht hier leider
meine redezeit nicht mehr aber gerade
auch die sprach mit lung im
gesundheitswesen es mir ein wichtiges
anliegen denn auch dass es prävention
dass menschen die sprachbarrieren haben
besser behandelt werden können
zielgerichteter verstehen was ärztinnen
und ärzte ihnen zu vermitteln versuchen
deshalb lassen sie uns gemeinsam in
diesem haushaltsentwurf gucken dass wir
überflüssige kosten im gesundheitswesen
durch vernünftige präventionsmaßnahmen
verhindern dazu werde ich mich gern mit
in die beratungen einbringen und freue
mich drauf vielen dank
[Applaus]